okay so here we are eating our feed my
name is nikki
today my friend patrick has challenged
me to make a smoked watermelon that
looks like meat
i just don't understand food pretending
to be other food you eat with your eyes
i don't like the confusion of putting it
in your mouth and being like this is not
the thing i thought i was putting in my
mouth so not only do i have to make this
watermelon look like a ham i have to
make a smoker
yes that'll be real easy and fun right
because if i'm ever in a blind
yeah it started at this restaurant in
new york called ducks eatery
there is a food insider video where they
like interview the chef william horowitz
he walks through the process of how to
make this you first have to like skin
the watermelon you have to take the rind
off he brines it and then he dries it
and then it's smoked for
like a half of a day and then it's
sliced up and served
as if you would meet as always to help
with every episode
is our wonderful friend riya
hi this is what i'm doing today i didn't
know there was such a trend
i feel like chefs experimenting
using you know like classic technique
for
cooking meat to applying to vegetable
whatever the outcome is
you will learn how to smoke if i do this
successfully will i walk away being able
to actually smoke a ham
yes you have a lot of skills under your
belt
okay i see that i see that all right
well sounds good
i'll keep you in the loop cool as they
say i will set my
bala so please do set that bar very low
okay good luck bye i have a lot of work
to do
yeah first steps d rinding a watermelon
you have these two choice watermelons
patrick gave a preference
bigger will look better bigger is better
i need to get the enzyme to make flat
bottoms which i think will then make
the rest of the rind coming off around a
little bit easier because it'll be on a
flat surface what does this tell you
i'm too short now i'm ready oh god
oh it's really slanted it's not a
straight line at all
it's fine you like that i can get the
other side
that seems flatter so that's this point
it's just a matter of
that oh but i need to like cut deep
enough that the rind actually comes off
does it look meaty yet it does actually
i'm like a barber
might there be an argument for keeping a
little bit of the rind on
for the smoking process i think so maybe
that's like the fat
i love it i think you're ready yay so
next up is brining
the process of soaking something in
water with salt it's like a thing you
can do to meat
to make it flavorful and infuse it based
on the insider video and how he brined
the watermelon they talk about this
ingredient called oakwood ash
which helps in this brining process to
develop some sort of skin
we couldn't find it so this is what
we're doing i'm just going to eyeball
these
measurements it's water a lot of salt
i'm going to put too much in
isn't that a thing when there's too much
salt and water it like comes to a point
where it won't dissolve anymore
okay some coriander and oregano
twister all right now for the plop
this looks ridiculous big fruity
basketball
that's a brine and there's a naked
watermelon we're gonna put this in the
fridge
and brine it overnight and i guess magic
will happen next we're gonna go to a
hardware store and hopefully
start putting together a smoker okay
believe it or not this is
my soon to be smoker my smoker fiance
i'm making a cardboard box
diy smoker modeled after
what alton brown has done on tv in his
show good eats
this is obviously like the smoker
container
in which we will put everything we got a
couple of dowel rods
to rest our watermelon on top of inside
the box
will be this roasting pan an electric
burner a cast iron skillet which then we
have to fill with
wood chips a pie plate that will cut
some holes in which will be a smoke
diffuser
dowel rods kind of like going right
across one of these and then we'll put
the watermelon on top the box will be
full of smoke that's it
we need to cover up the logos on this
box i thought maybe we could draw
something on it
i drew a watermelon i drew us and then i
said don't touch me i'm a smoking hot
watermelon that's adam with glasses and
a beard
okay it needs a butt flap the only thing
the buffalo needs to be big enough for
is my hands
i think to get oh god i totally missed
that
there's a possibility that your wood
chips will
disintegrate and become no longer wood
chips and you might have to replace them
so i'm just going to start cutting
okay that's done so we have three dowels
so i think i only need two
now the trick is to poke holes on each
side i want to just see like how high
all of this stuff comes up to
the watermelon needs to be high enough
off of the smoker
you want to smoke the ham evenly yeah
that feels right
basically we'll put the dowel rods kind
of through here
hey it's definitely at an angle
but that's fine whatever
can we do one more so much crafting
today and there you have it
bada bing bada boom here's our backup
watermelon let's see if it uh holds up
that's the watermelon right there
oh wow i guess i could always just shave
off the top if i absolutely
yeah i need a hole in the box for the
cord of the electric hot plate and i
also need
access to the on off switch for the hot
plate itself so i could just kind of
like
cut open my roasting pan a bit don't do
this at home
it's a little janky but this whole thing
is a little jinky
yay just big enough okay my pie plate
needs
some holes you got to be firm oh
okay i think that'll dissipate smoke
okay i feel pretty like accomplished
actually
could i just put this on my patio like
one saturday and smoke some
meat your neighbors would truly not know
what the hell you're doing they'll just
be like where is that smell coming from
i don't know so the last thing to do is
to soak some wood chips
these are like wood chunks so almost the
whole bag
i think we're good good start adam just
looked it up for me because i was like
how long did i do this for and he was
like you don't have to soak wood chunks
smoker's done wood is wood and
watermelon is brining tomorrow we start
the grill tomorrow we smoke
oh my god it's so weird it's got a big
crack in it i thought you knew
i had no idea so much
oh it's so cold here's a smoker we gotta
take it outside because we cannot smoke
this inside
okay we've got the smoker by plugging
in the power to the hot plate this is
full of wood
all right lining it up so that's gonna
start heating and
the wood's gonna get hot and then
that'll turn into smoke in the meantime
i have my watermelon and i don't think
we want any of the herbs
on it while we smoke it also there's a
huge crack in it which i didn't realize
was there but apparently everybody else
did
it needs to dry it feels really silly to
be using towels
to dry off a watermelon because by
nature should be wet
but two thermometers so i think we want
to aim for the temperature of the box
and like the smoke in the box to be
about 180. we'll see if we get there
the other one will go into the
watermelon so when you set the
temperature for the alarm
there's like different animals to tell
you like what temperature it should cook
at
i think it's so stupid to use the
reference point for internal temperature
for a watermelon
with a ham because they are completely
different consistencies
you know what let's just play along and
let's just use the ham one which is 160.
it is currently
45 degrees so it's got a long
oh my god okay i'm gonna close this oh
it's now 93
in there wow this is actually working
this box is going to get very hot in the
alton brown video he says
like if you stop seeing smoke that's
like a signal of when you should change
the wood chips he also did use sawdust
instead of wood chunks so it's kind of
like apples to oranges we can definitely
keep an eye on it
i need a little lawn chair
[Applause]
this is kind of nice i guess oh hello
at the office oh okay what's your name i
was just calling you back
three days later good job i'm sorry well
i'm busy
why are you calling me right now i'm
smoking a watermelon
okay can i go back to work now yes hey i
love you
let me buy boxes 129. center of the
watermelon is still 43. it's been about
two hours the temperature of the box
is hovering very close to 180 and the
inside of the watermelon temperature is
63.
there's significantly less smoke coming
out of the box and i think
that's because it's time to change out
the wood chunks or at the very least
check them
whoa quick quick
very hot more more more great so i think
we can do
another like smoke check around two
hours oh my god okay
the heat in the box is rising quickly we
don't want anything to explode so i
think you turn it down to medium oh god
i can't see anything oh my god
it can't be done
abandoned ship i can't keep
like a face full of smoke
adam's alternative suggestion was just
to unplug the hot plate which i have
just done
but the temperature is still rising and
there's 192. okay it's been
four hours these are patrick's
sunglasses here let me use them
it is kind of that like two hour mark
where we should probably swap out the
wood but i'm a little scared because
last time i opened the buff up i almost
died
whoa okay we're in business yeah wow the
internal temp of the box dropped
down to 187. the melons still at 93.
it seems pretty unlikely that the
watermelon is gonna hit an internal
temperature of 160 degrees but we do
want it to be warm enough
i think we give it another two hours
it's been about six hours the watermelon
temperature is at 108 it's like almost
the other day
and i feel like 108 is like a fine
temperature for watermelon best time
now's the time i've been waiting for two
days and we get to open this
oh
it formed a skin it looks smoked which
is great that's really all i could ask
for
great job thank you okay so this was in
the oven
just to keep it warm while we were
getting everything else set up
it's so ugly it's like wet soft baby
skin so now i'm just going to score it
like ham
it's like juicing this is very strange
you know this kept its shape pretty well
yeah it did oops i really don't know
it's fine oh it's not so bad also there
might be some nice scoring on the
underside
that's from like the grill okay so now i
baste it and it's
juices some olive oil and a
rosemary oh my god
that was incredibly unsafe i'm okay
it's also just way too big oh yeah
i need those long gloves on again now
i'm protected
and i can't pick up this spoon i think
it's stuck to them
really how could it be that i don't know
ah flipping it to see if we can get a
little bit of color on the rest of it
wow flavor city right there i don't want
these to burn and taste weird
how often is it that you taste something
you've never tasted before
i know maybe i could be tasting a
new flavor that really tickles my fancy
i don't know if it looks any more like a
ham
in the viral video like you can tell
that the watermelon
looks much more like a ham got a little
bit more of like charred
darker marks to it and it has like a
gelatinous and like squishy
texture i don't think i have those so
i'm going to throw this in the broiler
10 minutes and see if there's a change
hi riya
hi i brought you watermelon thank you so
much
maybe we can eat a real one i had to put
it in the boiler okay the last time i
checked it it looked like it was
changing tingey's good they're great
yeah cool okay so i'm just gonna go take
it out now and then we can take a look
oh wow look at that looks like a ham
look at that i have no idea how to get
it out of this maybe i can hold
the cutting board closer you can just
like great thank you
oh it's so slippery good good
yes wow
wow beautiful three water melons
this is definitely better than what we
had in 15 minutes ago
all right cut it okay
this kind of look like roasted beef like
it's very
yeah there's like parts of it that look
like yeah beef more than ham right yeah
yeah yeah it's not super ginger look i
saw jiggle
[Music]
okay you've really truly done it whoa
okay
okay today i have prepared for you
confused watermelon
should we eat it yeah yeah yeah cheers
one two three
[Music]
oh
oh it's so tart
this kind of reminds me of a pickle yeah
really smoky pig yeah
it does look like rare meat
[Music]
you know what this actually tastes
exactly like kool-aid pickle
it makes them sweet and it also makes
them this color
he's gonna like it yeah i like the smoky
it's definitely
ringing a little too loud but if you
tone it down by a couple decibels
they spill
that's my audio analogy for this these
are like great depression snacks
yeah let's eat that that was great let's
see which one's tastier
oh yes certainly a worthy opponent
patrick really liked it
i learned a lot and i'm 100 sure that
the restaurant has made something that
like is
exponentially tastier than this as a
food imposter this is like 10 out of 10
you know yeah good job thank you
i want someone to like make like a stock
sound track of like people
eating and enjoying watermelon is just
slurping and you going